they've made our world bleed but we
don't stand alone a brave few have sworn
to protect us and save what remains may
you yes remind us that we are one people
they are our shield and our light but if
that light goes out
who can save us then
[Music]
like its predecessor the division 2 has
a centralized command location known as
the base of operations but the way
things work in this new boo with the
addition of settlements is a little
different in this video we're going to
cover the new base of operations what
we've seen of the settlements so far and
how they work together those of you who
were able to try the private beta last
weekend will probably know a lot of this
information but in preparation for the
open beta and the full release of the
game I wanted to share some insight into
some of the game aspects that have
changed as I'm sure everyone is aware by
now our new base of operations is
located in the White House and much like
the base of operations in New York not
everything is available straight away
you need to unlock an upgrade to be able
to take full advantage of all the
vendors and the stations throughout you
know places like the crafting and
recalibration station but unlike the
division one we don't have any wings to
unlock instead these areas are unlocked
by finding and recruiting staff to work
in the White House and where do we find
these people to recruit well this is
where the new settlements come in
settlements are locations where
civilians who survive the outbreak have
come together armed themselves
walled-off an area and are trying to
rebuild there are four settlements
across the map and each has its own
leader these areas are essentially
another safe zone for us to utilize sort
of a mix between a boot and a safehouse
each settlement has a number of missions
some are a part of the main storyline
but others are just smaller side
missions and there are also a number of
projects that could be anything from
rescuing son or donating some armor
pieces once you've completed a number of
objectives you're given someone from the
settlement to be a new staff member that
will now be located in the White House
unlocking various stations and/or areas
also included in the settlements as your
standard stash chests a vendor
matchmaking and even some kids you can
dance with if you feel like entertaining
some of the locals
like the division-one skills and perks
still need to be unlocked but instead of
the tech ones there is a one-stop shop
for everything skills and perks related
head over to the quartermaster is one of
the first people you'll see when
entering the base of operations skills
seem to all be available from the get-go
and can be unlocked in any order you
like so for example you can focus
completely on drones to start with or
the chem launcher as I said before this
footage is from the early acces to the
private beta in Sydney and the beta from
the weekend just passed so a lot of the
skills were unavailable perks are much
the same they're all laid out in front
of you and you can choose to start
anywhere you'd like though there are
certainly a few you'd want to focus on
first like the ability to equip a second
weapon and holding more armor kits some
of these perks are tiered meaning that
you can unlock them several times to
increase the bonus for example you can
unlock the ability to hold another
armored cap called a total of 4 and then
5 and then 6 all of the skills and perks
require shd tech to unlock shd Tech is
our first currency that we need to find
but fortunately this isn't too hard to
get ahold of all of the missions that
were available in the beta provided shd
tech on completion as did the side
missions and even some of the projects
that are mentioned earlier are based
solely around collecting shd tech from
around the open world obviously this was
just the beta and we were only able to
get up to level 7 but there are a number
of other people to visit in the boot -
obviously we have the vendor in the main
entrance located across from the
quartermaster and upstairs we can check
on our projects and how we're tracking I
said earlier that all perks can be
sorted at the quartermaster but this
isn't quite true on the top floor we
have the dark zone officer where we can
unlock some more perks to further
enhance our abilities in the dark zone
things like the contamination bag space
and dark zone experience gain these open
up as your dark zone level increases to
the right of the entrance we have the
PvP area where we can access all of the
PvP related content including the stats
on the various PvP game modes that
you've played down behind the PvP area -
the back of the white house we have the
clan quarters obviously this wasn't
unlocked for the beta but peering
through the gaps you get a little bit of
an idea of what's happening in the space
our crew on the discord are pretty
excited about this we've even started
making lists for the clans on each
platform if
you're interested jump on in I have a
link in the description as I said
earlier running through the storyline
will open up a hell of a lot more in the
base of operations right now it might
seem a little bit empty but there's
still a few things we're trying to
figure out as we've just finished up the
private beta and we're about to see the
open beta go live in the next little
while I'm not going to be talking about
the technical state of the game there
are plenty of videos out there already
the open beta finishes just over a week
out from the full release so to be fair
it's actually more of a demo than a beta
so from here we'll have a better feel of
what to expect in the main game do I
think everything will be fixed no but I
think it'll be in a much better place
than what we've seen so far instead I'm
just gonna release a couple of videos to
help with figuring out some of the
changes to the original game and
preparation for the demo and full
release things like the video you've
just seen but also I'll try to cover a
few things that might not be so obvious
straight away like the weapons and
builds anyway I hope this has gotten you
a little more prepared for how to use
the new base of operations and
settlements if you have any further
questions about these new areas let me
know in the comments below otherwise
I'll catch you in the next one Cheers
[Music]
you